[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm life what's going on guys you know
we we have been away for far too long it
I I if I remember correctly the week
before last I went to New York so that's
why I canceled that one because I was
still packing I started to get a haircut
there's still so much stuff I had to do
and what's funny is that week
the the reviews for God of War dropped
and then the week after that the game
came out but I was playing it and I was
like no absolutely not so so it's just
uh it is what it is we missed two weeks
uh and most likely I'm gonna take a lot
of December off too you know we need
time to regenerate people be acting like
podcasting is coming in a in a zoom call
or a Discord and talk for two hours and
then not pick up anything from the
podcasting life
and then it doesn't continue to the week
after like
this is a commitment I don't think
people realize how much this is a
commitment yeah
expect you know especially dirt because
you know you you do extra stuff on your
podcast like you you have like segments
and stuff like that man this is just
like a free like you ain't getting
nothing like that from me I'm gonna be
real with you guys like I'm a very pop
in talk about toxic subject kind of
person you ain't gonna get me doing the
stuff that is dirt does because dirt
actually prepares for his show okay I
was playing ogre tactics until about 10
minutes ago
laughs
all right so that's pretty much how that
went I did make a video today uh people
that beat God of War definitely go check
out my video on my actual Channel gaming
addict I talked a lot about about you
know some of the the nitpicks I had for
the game in terms of spoiling content so
don't go on there and expect you're not
going to get spoiled it literally says
spoiled spoilers in in the comment
section it is what it is
um and another thing man I appreciate
everyone that came through to mine and
King's show last night it's the first
time we ever did it it's kind of like
it's not gaming it's about movies and TV
shows and I really enjoyed it because
it's it's a fresher breath air when you
talk about games all the time I don't
think you guys realize
I I don't even do Twitter that much
anymore like you know with this Elon
Mustang going on people's like added
what you think I was like well
considering I'm seeing people getting
banned for like light to like light
stuff like I saw uh people get banned
just for retaliating against people
attacking them so people will literally
go make a dummy account
an attack a content creator and when he
retaliates who cares that the dumb
account gets banned it's a dummy account
in the in the actual content creator
gets banned so it's just like
I feel like something needed to change
on Twitter now I don't know if it's Elon
Musk I'll be right with you but but you
know hopefully hopefully things get
better because it's yeah it's looking
pretty spooky right now yeah it's crazy
on Twitter right now man
so
thanks for coming through this to the
attic show where we talked about the
past present future game I got my calls
with me Dirk griggity what's going on
Dirk what's going on
what's up homie it's been a couple weeks
man what's going on with you
um pretty much the same thing you know I
went to New York
never been to New York before that uh
you guys can keep that
it was it was a very uh chaotic
experience you know what's funny is cog
picked me up from the airport and it was
like
like an hour and a half Drive
to get like like 20 miles
oh wow because I guess it was just so
much traffic it was Unreal yeah you guys
can keep that I I ain't trying to to
deal with that uh Cog did introduce me
to this pizza
you know the famous New York Pizza I
will say it's the best pizza I've ever
had what's funny is cog was attacking me
because uh he was like why didn't you
say it was the best pizza you've ever
had in the tweet and I was like because
I only got a certain amount of
characters to tweet with but yes it was
the best pizza I've ever had but
the way you guys in New York be talking
about this pizza
when I ate that I expected to become
like like I expected super powers I
expected to grow wings I expected to be
able to jump 20 miles you know it when I
ate it it just tasted like really good
pizza like it wasn't I I and then I just
don't book The Chicken they got out
there that's different that actually
tasted see here's the thing like
I got Mom and Pop pizzas here places
here it doesn't
it's Pizza is not as good as New York
pizza but I wouldn't put it like so far
ahead you know what I'm saying right but
the only place I got really got to sell
be chicken is is like KFC so like that
was different that was that was good
that was really good
so what what you've been doing here the
past two weeks what's been going on with
you man I've been actually playing games
man um oh God playing games see what's
funny is is when we talk about playing
games people don't want to hear none of
that you know what's funny you'll you'll
get you we got like 53 people probably
get like a couple hundred in here by the
end of the show they come in here but
you know a lot of these people wouldn't
show up if we were streaming games which
is okay it's a different cut it's a
different crowd I get it I do get it
it's a different crowd but it is be
funny man it'd be funny how uh you know
when it comes to the gaming portion
people people be missing they'd be
missing in action but if you're talking
about games they'd be hearing a
heartbeat
well you know I've learned that as far
as my channel the people that sub to my
channel they sub to hear my opinion
about games you know like whether I'm
talking trash or or my honest opinion so
that's that that's what I do I just talk
about my opinion but
yeah I've been playing games man um you
know I'm playing God of War I actually
got um
attacked for playing God Awards you know
like somebody called me a fake Xbox dude
because I'm playing God of War it's
pretty funny
um so yeah I feel like we don't have
access to the same games like they
really do I made a video that was pretty
much like I'm kind of concerned for the
story of God of War which my concerns
were kind of right but it wasn't at the
same time but people were sitting there
you just bad because you don't get the
game
um what like really seriously like what
like yeah this is a PlayStation
controller fam like yeah sometimes I
that's where I feel like the console war
things
exceeds my tolerance like when it's just
like joking or like J double tagged me
in something that's one thing or you
know when some of these PlayStation
people like poke me with a stick that's
one thing but then like when you act
like I don't have access to your games
that's where I feel like the mental
steak thing comes in because it's like
you know we most of us have PlayStation
fives
would say most PlayStation owners don't
have Xboxes though so I so it's pretty
much confirmed and Xbox people talk
about PlayStation we got that [ __ ] when
PlayStation people talk about Xbox they
don't got that [ __ ]
so what else
see let me say this right quick
the thing with me though just imagine I
know you're not into sports that much
but just imagine you have your favorite
team
you have your favorite team in the early
90s the late 80s I was I'm from Detroit
I'm a big Detroit Piston fan I wanted
the Detroit Pistons to beat the Chicago
Bulls right because I was a piston fan
but at the same time I respected Michael
Jordan
I like Michael Jordan game that that
didn't mean I'm not a big a a Detroit
Piston fan that means I like Michael
Jordan but I still want to see my team
win so these guys came at me oh man you
a fake ass box fan you bought God of War
you spent a thousand dollars for your
PS5 I don't know where they get that
from but uh you know it's just too much
man so
um it's just at the point
where you show you're a true gamer yes
I'm I like Xbox I prefer Xbox I consider
myself an Xbox dude but I guess you you
have to be a blind Xbox fan in order to
call yourself Xbox fan yeah it's crazy
and it's just crazy you know here
recently I haven't really been called a
PlayStation Fanboy but I remember
there'll be so many iops where I will
talk negatively on Xbox and people say
people be calling me a fat boy it's just
like it happens on both sides it does
yeah but and that's where I have to like
jab at the Xbox Community a little bit
like when I criticize does not mean I
don't love this ecosystem and like what
the Cubs is like I'm playing tactics oh
girl on on PC
and the part that irritates me is it's
not on Xbox I'm playing let's see you
could see like right here hold up
oh my God right here you see this that's
that's that's my Elite controller so I'm
playing because if you look my laptop's
like right here so I'm I'm playing steam
uh with the HDMI hooked up to my TV
because I ain't trying to sit at this
chair I said it to chair enough I I like
to play my games laid back unless I'm
playing like something like a rage or or
I'm reviewing something because then I
have to actually get gameplay so I have
the HDMI cord hooked up to the TV and I
and I'm that's what I've been doing it's
just like I've been playing Tactics Ogre
and the longer I play it the more I get
irritated it's like why isn't this game
on Xbox like yeah I just I get it it's a
Square Enix game and you know we'll get
into that because I do have a little bit
of a topic when it comes to that but you
know I actually am really big fan of
everything that's been going on right
now you know uh pendant that gaming has
has has been good the past past like
month and I hope it continues so
so uh dirt you know well I think we're
gonna start with this ABK update man you
know I don't like talking about this but
I do think this is relevant enough to
bring up
looks like Phil Spencer is bending the
knee to the pressure and it's been real
I don't know if like it's a hundred
percent like it's happening but
he's like I'm I'm more open to having
Call of Duty on Playstation longer so
what do you think about that man do you
think he should bend the knee to this to
this to this company that is making
unreasonable because if you're looking
at like these officials that's tweeting
about
about you know his personal catalog on
Playstation if I was if I was filled I'd
probably yeah maybe I needed to do
something like they've clearly got
people in the house like to to bring my
deal down yeah uh I I think it's just
that Phil's at the point where they want
to get the deal done
um he's letting it be known they don't
want to prolong this deal any longer
than it has to be I feel they are like
you mentioned before I feel that wanting
this deal to get done so they can can
continue buying Studios continue adding
teams to Xbox game studios and they want
to get it done
um we heard about the initial offer that
Xbox offered them three extra years of
Call of Duty and that's it obviously
that didn't go over well with Jimmy boy
that didn't go over well so yeah so now
field Sprints for saying look man you
guys can keep Call of Duty natively
you know no streaming they don't have to
take Game Pass and I just feel they're
trying to get this deal done because as
you know at it
Call of Duty is PlayStation's main focus
ABK
King is a huge Focus for Xbox for
Microsoft Phil Spencer also said that
they feel if they don't invest in Mobile
uh I forget the word that he used but
pretty much saying um that could hurt
them in the long run if they're not into
Mobile as a gaming company a section of
my uh like the gaming section of
Microsoft so I feel that
field right here take Heart Of Duty just
shut up and take Call of Duty we want
this deal done
like as I said it's more than Call of
Duty
this deal is much more important than
just Call of Duty
so you can say he bent the knee
I'm like yeah he's kind of like you know
STFU
and take the damn game yeah
that's right I didn't mean like bend the
knee in a bad way I mean yeah yeah I
know what you're saying they put me in a
situation where I'ma just have to give
them what they want to some degree
because there's more variables in this
deal than Call of Duty and I want all of
those and not just Call of Duty I do
think that
if Sony tries to throw out some stuff
like we don't want Call of Duty and Game
Pass I'm curious if that's going to okay
then we're going to court we're going to
court absolutely listen if somebody's
trying to say yo no game pass or even
the eu's trying to say okay that's fine
but no Gamepad no no no no no now we're
going to court because you can't tell
them exactly you know if there's an
agreement that they will continue to
keep it on Playstation that's one thing
but for them to say you can't put it in
Game Pass no that's in BS no absolutely
not so I agree with you David you know
what we're gonna have to go to court on
that one because we're putting it in
Game Pass after some of these contract
is up or whatever you know yes they're
putting it in Game Pass
do you think that when it comes to
Call of Duty do you think that putting
that in Game Pass is gonna like have a
huge significance
oh absolutely
um I'm not saying those playing on
Playstation right now will leave the
PlayStation ecosystem
but then again maybe if they or one of
the few people that have a Xbox as well
as a PlayStation or if they're on PC
unless they're a pony
let's be honest some people might say
hey man um I can play it over here and
they just it's in the service I already
have and I don't have to spend 70 bucks
on it an additional 70 dollars
so I do believe there will be a lot of
people that move to the Xbox ecosystem
I'm not saying all
but there will be a big amount of people
that move to the Xbox ecosystem
including some of the people
that haven't upgrade yet that haven't
upgraded to Next Generation yet
that's why I kind of feel like yeah just
getting Call of Duty is not going to be
enough I I feel like
their aim they might save for
competition wise but their aim is to
stop Call of Duty from going in game
past day to day no I think that's right
yeah gonna have a fight because to me
getting Call of Duty is going to be fine
but the only variables that really
change is that going in Game Pass and I
feel like their mindsets look it might
not hurt as short-term marketing also
yeah and the marketing is really big too
that's probably just as big and I think
their mindset's like right now we'll be
fine but who to say in two to three
years that market shift doesn't happen
because we lost Call of Duty and it's
like I said over and over again like
Call of Duty
You could argue that the people that's
on the Call of Duty marketing rights
have won every generation absolutely and
it's sad but it's just like
people don't realize how big Call of
Duty is like just because you don't play
I'm not a big Call of Duty fan it
doesn't mean millions of people don't
play that every year
well I know you just seen it seem like
the record they just broke man
they just broke a record out of all of
the Call of Duties this past one that
just released broke records the biggest
seller the quickest selling Call of Duty
of all time one billion dollars made in
10 days correct 10 days man
I couldn't even fathom what's like to
have a billion dollars
like I can sit here and try to tell you
I'd be Noble but I'd be a villain like I
know I'd be a villain I'd be going up to
like gas stations and some like a
worker's route to me so I buy the
franchise just to personally fire that
one person
and that's a villain stuff right there
Addie yeah I would be a villain I know I
would and see the good thing is like
I've always been transparent man I've
always been transparent I think I would
still have my personality
but I'm Petty by Nature yeah and most of
the time I can control that pettiness
but I don't know what I would be
I don't know how bad that pettiness
would get if I had real money to be
Petty with right you'll be like 50 Cent
right you know I don't know if you heard
the story you're 50 Cent by 250 tickets
to a Ja Rule concert just to have the
front row look empty that's he really
did that yeah that's a true story but
it's a couple years ago he bought I
believe he said 250 front row tickets
for Ja Rule concert just to make it look
empty
and you know I I would probably do
something like that for the people that
have never invited IOP to something like
uh because we we try to get in the Video
Game Awards and it's not that they
wouldn't respond to us but I don't think
that like you know Jeff Keely really
knows us that well to invite us or
something like that just buy all the all
the video game tickets the video game
will wear tickets only people there's
press
yeah or or pay people to when it says
clap to not clap
that'll be fun yeah that's Petty that's
top level pettiness right there it's fun
Petty though I'm not hurting no one I I
okay besides the person I get fired at
Sheets okay that that might hurt their
life but you know and not to mention my
pettiness would generate me more money
because I'm buying businesses it's going
to generate money so there you go I
don't is it really that bad I don't is
it no it's not all right so you know
it's not we ain't really gonna talk too
much about the that topic because I feel
like
I feel like right now they can say
anything they want they need to see more
information in general we need to see
more information I'm kind of curious on
what happens with like OverWatch and
stuff like that because to me I feel
like
all those characters should come to Game
Pass just like they're doing with the
violent games so but you know what to
see let's let's talk about
God of War versus Elder ring the the
the what's one I'm looking for
it's
going to go down next month on the 8th
it's going to go down and what's funny
is stray got in there you know we'll
talk about that in a little bit in the
Video Game Awards I'm still a little
upset over that
but I think we can all agree that for
the most part we all know it's going to
be either Elden ring or God of War and
I'm first off everyone in the chat put a
one if you think Eldon Rings winning it
actually I'll just put a poll in the
chat I'll just put a poll in the track
no no point for that so dirt
what do you think is going to win game
of the year
I remember you asked this question a few
months ago
and at the time I said Elder ring
because
I know God of War is going to be a
massive game
um huge game and it's obviously that
I said elderly because if you remember
when elderly came out man it was just
the Talk of the Town everybody was
talking about the game I believe he got
what 96 on Metacritic it sold well and I
was like I think elderly is going to be
hard to beat and I still feel the same
way but I do believe God of War is a
damn good game I'm playing it right now
I was I was actually playing it right
before the show it's a good game but I
just believe it Elder ring
even though I prefer God of War of the
elderly elderly really isn't my cup of
tea
I just think it was just too huge even
though it was way earlier this year and
some people might forget how big Elder
ring was but it was it was a huge game
man and even though God of War is also a
huge game I'm thinking hey on the ring
because I'm here like like out of wore
one was it 2018 yeah they won before I
know from software one with Shakira was
that 2019 one year yeah but we'll see
man we'll see I'm thinking Elder rain is
going to win I actually personally feel
like
Eldon ring deserves it look I think God
of War is a fantastic game but there's a
lot of issues with God of War in certain
aspects Elden ring wasn't anything
special by any means when it come to
like the formula but they took that
formula they evolved it and then
injected that evolved form with steroids
like that
Eldon ring has some of the most
submersion I've ever seen in my entire
life like when you're playing Elden ring
hours will go by now I'm not saying that
doesn't happen with god of war god of
war is a very good game
but I will say when Eldon ring came out
when god of war came out
I feel like the energy was different
like for a good two to three weeks
Eldon ring owned the internet it might
have been called Eldon Rings internet
yeah I'm not saying that God of War is
not getting something like that but what
I will say is I'm not seeing the same
reception that the Eldon Marine got and
maybe it's because it's a a multiply I
mean maybe because Eldon Ring's a
multi-plat god award's an exclusive
and maybe that's the majority of the
reason you're not seeing like the why
variety because like Elder ring PC
people had access to it Xbox access to
it I mean everyone really did with
switch uh we got a two dollar super
truck from flame sorry added triangle
strategies better fight me
uh I'm six foot four
about 270 pounds I don't know if you
want to fight me
there you go man I don't know yeah I
know you said Tom yeah I I I'm gonna
just say that for you I'm just saying
that but I didn't say you don't want no
smoke bro yeah you wanna swim
I wouldn't be surprised that God wore
one and I wouldn't be upset if God of
War won uh I do feel like personally
Elden ring is the one that deserves it
but I wouldn't be surprised if God award
got it as well yeah
you uh set a plane bro it was like a
three-week hype train listen I knew I
wasn't going to like elderin because I
don't like from software games but even
I still bought it because the hype was
just that real on that game everybody
was buying it it got great Metacritic
scores and I was like damn do I need to
I just need to buy it just to play it
for a second you know is this game going
to be different than any other from
software game and like I said it still
wasn't my thing but I you know I have it
I might give this another shot one of
these days but it the hype was crazy for
him
bro and like you said maybe because it
was a multi-plat
um I remember it just totally
stole Horizon forbidden West Thunder bro
nobody cared about prices for being West
because it came out with like a week
outfit on the ring or no I'm sorry
elderly came out a week after Horizon I
believe was or something like that they
came out close to each other
and it just totally killed all high for
rising and I was like wow it's a huge
game well the funny thing is how it lost
all of that spark it got look I mean
we'll get to the the video game award
things here in a minute uh I think we'll
go briefly over some of the top
categories I'm not going over all the
Esports stuff nothing like that uh
firstly I don't understand why that's
there he must be getting a pretty big
bag to have there's almost Justice
Esports nominations there is like big
nominations it's crazy but when it comes
to this I I do feel like
God of War has did a good job on a
narrative space
but the immersion's there a little bit
but I feel like it's like I said that
immersion on Eldon ring where you know
you you can go anywhere you want to go
you get lost in the game people and I
think what really helped out on ring is
you could do that you could tackle that
game in multiple ways so I was in the
Grand City it's like where all the
knights and stuff are and when I'm
talking to kids smooth and to other
people some of them went a completely
different way
or some of them found secrets that took
them to that City so that really helps
when you have these kind of moments that
other people can't share and I think you
look at it from that perspective
God of War for the most part were all
playing God War the exact same way just
some of us might be playing out on the
hardest difficulty that's the only Road
difference and I think that is what
really captivates eldering above that is
that illusion of freedom and the the
illusion that you can do anything you
want people love those type of of of of
games people love being able to play a
game the way they want to play it and
not necessarily the way everyone else
wants a play that doesn't mean God of
War doesn't have play Styles they got
multiple weapons that you can use but
for the most part
you're not doing anything different than
switching between those weapons like on
Eldon ring you you can have magic builds
tank builds uh there's a lot of
different aspects and the different
opinions that you can do you can't be a
tank in in God of War you can get stats
up to take more hits but you can't truly
be a tank in God of War
I agree what's right there so we're
we've come to we think so you think
Eldon ring is going to get at the end
right yes sir yes sir it's going to be
interesting uh this sun this Saturday
IOP is doing uh the crown the Lord thing
where you know we're gonna go over pick
up all the
the options for everything and then we
tally them all up and that's the that's
the one that won the Video Game Awards
uh last year saw solved one last year
the year before that me and King got
tied okay and then solved one the year
before Cognito has never won a crown the
Lord not one time and we've been doing
it for what three years at this point
this first second this is the fourth
year cassava won the first one uh King
and me won the second one saw one the
third one and this would be the fourth
one five dollar super trap from dawn to
talk Australia is the most overrated
game in uh to ever get nominated for
Game of the Year it's the only game I've
ever felt doesn't even deserve to be on
the list we're going to get to that
we're gonna get to that dog
let's let me get the time stamp please
hold up yeah man hey man you know they
don't play that message
and we'll say 10 seconds
um
let's talk about God of War
what is your overall opinions about God
of War like things that stood out to you
in the first like few hours of the game
um okay first off it is a beautiful game
you can tell it's a it's a PS4 game this
is really beautiful though it's a
beautiful game
um so far I'm enjoying it I'm I'm still
kind of early I believe I'm at the part
where you're playing as uh atreus so I'm
you know and you're looking for the uh
like the woman I can think of her name
so I'm probably still early in the game
uh but so far I'm I'm enjoying it man I
enjoy the franchise I'm not one of them
guys that's gonna lie about what I like
and flip you know then flip just for my
my fan base or not fan base I hate to
say that we're not celebrities the
people that rock out with me
um so I'm not gonna do that but um yeah
so far I'm enjoying it it's um
you know it it's God of War it's it's
similar to 2018 but that's a good thing
in my opinion
um so I have a feelings to get like you
did so I so far I'm truly enjoying it
the war
does a lot of things right man and I can
honestly say that it's a very good game
and I really enjoy it I think people
expected
different things from God of War for
some reason like look I'm not gonna say
that we don't deserve you know certain
aspects of God of War in a better light
like but at the same time like we got to
understand that until they make
that exclusive part we're not going to
get the god of war that you want I do
feel like there was a lot of aspects to
God of War that felt very last gen
yeah but it's like I said it is a
last-gen game it was just cross promoted
uh just so they can make that money and
it's good that they did that
um here's the thing if they would have
made what we what you guys wanted it
would have cost way more money than what
they had right uh because it would take
a long time to actually catch up to that
momentum that you guys want because if
you guys want that game they're gonna
have to remake the game pretty much so
it would have took probably an extra
year and a half depending on how far of
the development cycle they was before
they got the PlayStation 5 Dev kits uh
and not to mention the money too just
because you want a game
to perform exactly how you want the game
to perform doesn't mean it's going to
sell well so you could have potentially
had a scenario where God of War sells
better but then on the adjacent side
because we pushed it for next gen only
it flops and sells them they don't they
don't reinvest in the franchise right so
I would prefer I'm always over what
what's good for the industry what's good
for the game that's why I'm okay with
what happened I think it's a good game I
think people should definitely go out
there and play it I got a review on the
IOP channel the channel that you are
currently watching this on you know so
you can go definitely go watch that uh
we got a five dollar super trip from
Hector Macho Man
uh what good what good addicts and dirt
Sony telling Xbox what to do with the
ABK is like buying a house and the
neighbor watch says you can't put put in
a pool there's actually some
associations that won't let you put in
pools
so you can in fact buy a house and have
someone else tell you what and what not
to do with it it's kind of crazy I don't
even know why people would move into
these kind of sections like that has
like a uh I don't know what exactly the
name is I'm sure someone in the comment
section lives in a boozy ass
neighborhood that has one of those yeah
but there are there are neighborhoods
like that yeah no you cannot
to a certain height and you can't put in
certain things because they think it's
going to devalue the the actual yeah and
I'm just like but you bought the
property it's not like you're renting it
right yeah and what's funny is it's
enforceable
the oh uh HOA HOA yeah homeowners
association I don't I don't understand
how it's enforceable like if you're not
going to hurt no one or put it over
anyone's property why can they take you
to Legal Court over it you know what I'm
saying like it's crazy maybe it's like
part of the city and that's why they do
it but we're working way off a topic I
don't know why but you know yeah I think
that
God of War
does exactly what we wanted it does God
of War from 2018
in a better light than they did in 2018.
I don't think it's anything like
spectacular special I think it's a
fantastic game but that's why I'm
leaning more towards Elder and ring
because it did do stuff different and it
did it better uh you know I personally
see God of War Ragnarok and it's
literally just a sequel from the 2018
version and and I don't know about you
but I'm playing on the performance most
that probably is going to affect my next
election I don't see the huge difference
in the way the games look I just don't
like I could clearly see there's clearly
a difference I feel like some of the
elements are different are more visually
approval there's a lot more things that
make sense
but
when you look at it from that standpoint
and you look at God of War Ragnarok
because I just played God of War 2018
like six months ago
it doesn't look a drastic difference you
if you were to tell me that there's four
year difference between Ragnarok and 18
I just say you lying because it doesn't
look that much of a of a huge jump
what do you think I think I agree with
you obviously the resolution is much
better you can see that it makes it you
know it kind of makes it pop a little
bit but yeah I mean like 2018 looked
amazing
so because this is pretty much a PS4
game also I'm not expecting it to look
that much better it does look a little
better but you know yeah you can see
it's not a lot just a little bit it's
the same yeah it gives a little bit but
but the resolution is obviously much
better uh not performance mode it feels
good but so yeah it looks similar but
that's to be expected like I said it's
still a PS4 game at the core it's still
the PS4 game yeah we got a 10 super set
from Cobb weave I live in one they
really have no power to really enforce
any of it I usually just tell them to
piss off they may find you but they
can't throw you out of your house or
anything how can they find you though
like is like is it like through the
state do you have to like go to the
courthouse and pay it or is it like an
association where you because to me if
they find you and they can't throw you
out of your house there's no there's no
consequences
like what do they go to come in there
like and like make you move your house
like to me if they can't make you leave
the neighborhood
how can they enforce any of it or even
find you because one would think the pre
the precautions of not paying that fine
would be getting thrown out of the house
or have to leave that place but you know
Cowboy definitely informed me on that
five dollar Super Chat from Alvin 2018 a
Ragnarok or like one big epic like the
two Kill Bill movies I look at one more
uh I look at one more like that than a
sequel I I feel you I think
um at the Kill Bill movies oh that's
funny I think that that's a good analogy
in a lot of different ways
look at something like
the original God of War Trilogy or the
Mass Effect Trilogy if you just picked
up and played God of War 3 without
playing the one and two
those games that game makes no sense to
you if anything you feel like it's going
too fast Mass Effect three the only
reason they're able to go
crazy in the third one where it's all
action pretty much and just stuff's
constantly going off because they built
up the story in the world they did a lot
of World building the first two games so
they was able to go into that I feel you
but here's my thing
I feel like 2018 I don't know about you
dirt
first off people I feel like I don't I
don't know nothing about North mythology
I didn't know who Boulder was before the
game
I feel like you literally could play
Ragnarok without having much information
on 18 and still be fine
yeah because well hell like they
actually got a recap on the title screen
but um yeah I agree with you because you
don't need to know
you know like the sun pretty much say
who he is in the story
um they they admit that you know how
life Freddy is so mad at him because
they killed because they killed the son
they pretty much say everything during
the game out of you know that's what I
mean like there was big points in the
first one yeah that game could have
literally you could not play that game
and play this game even without
the what happened in God of War 18 video
you could play this because I don't if
you really sit there and you think about
it well got a two dollar from drawing TJ
uh what's up guys what's up John hey
what's up John TJ how you doing buddy if
you really sit there and think about it
what really happened in 18 Boulder
showed up and you spin the game looking
for him that's literally what happens
well obviously you you you're looking to
spread the ashes of your of your your
spouse yeah that's literally the whole
game
They Don't Really introduce anyone
besides uh Freya and the whole game
pretty much well I guess you wouldn't
know where he's going on with uh Thor's
kids that you killed in the first one
the 18. but that's all that is literally
all
if you look at like I guess
a good analogy would be the first one
like God of War One
I you know sure
they didn't really go into a broad
Specter but you met Aries you met all of
the law all of the Gods in God of War
one because they uh bestowed you with
all those gifts yeah they did a lot
better job of explaining the world of
Greek mythology in the first one than
they did the 2018.
and so so that's where I'm going to go
with you on this what's better the old
Trilogy or these two games
oh oh man
um I love the the first trilogy I love
the first Trilogy I can fully answer
that question after I finish Ragnarok
um but I absolutely love the first
Trilogy like God of War 3 was the reason
I bought a PS3 like I had to play that
game part one part two was amazing
um oh man this action was just so
intense in part one two or three so
right now I'm saying the original
trilogy um but I'm going to have to
finish Ragnarok to get the full
my full opinion about it
I don't like what says this game
technically is supposed to close out the
story right I don't like when people say
Kratos didn't have emotions in the
original ones like
that's literally what Kratos was a
bundle of emotions that just got spot
out of control 24 7. like you guys
realize anger is an emotion right
absolutely like people act like anger
isn't an emotion like that's all he did
in the first three was be angry at
everything oh my God he was so damn mad
bro and I think that's what it irritates
me about these newer ones is like the
gore is gone it's it's it's not gone but
it's it's a fraction of what it used to
be yeah the sexual activities I could
have went with or without that but I do
feel like that helped bring this title
to more of a mature rating and that's
gone
you know
it's crazy like if you really think
about like
people
people really put god of war and I and I
and I could say this
was 100 certainty people looked at
something like God of War and said this
game is for adults
um
but I don't feel like the new regarded
Wars get that kind of reputation uh the
only thing you wouldn't want people
playing the newer God Awards is for
violence that's all right it's not gory
there's not blood going everywhere I saw
I was went up and I looked at God of War
3 executions
he literally cut someone's hand off and
started hitting them with it
like
it's it's just crazy like especially
look at just Medusa's head right he's
using someone's head as a weapon yeah
and a flashlight like who here was the
like the flashlight
I forgot who had it cut off and like use
it as a flashlight remember when he was
fighting um hamides or whatever the the
fast one that could fly or whatever yeah
and he ripped off one of his legs so he
couldn't keep flying like
I'm not to mention what he did to
Poseidon himself
well I really need the Hercules oh my
God man he just kept beating him over
and over again listen bro God award
three and I want to tell you the title
screen
is one of the most
fire title screens I ever seen this just
his face his anger this is fake as soon
as you press start it goes right to it
it goes right to it bro so yeah that
[ __ ] was fired man um
yeah
yeah and what's funny is I remember like
there would be certain scenarios where
Kratos would have to help someone get
out of like prisons and stuff to be able
to continue
and he would kill them anyway
yeah it's just it's just crazy and and
people first off the reason
he is as cold as heartless he is is
because
of what that man was has been through
tricking into killing his pen his family
yeah uh be pretty much being made to
work for people he didn't want to work
for I mean it literally the the first
god of war starts of him jumping off uh
I think it was Mount Olympics what or
something like that the tallest mountain
in Greece yeah to kill himself because
he's done with life
it like just that scene is more
emotional than almost I can't say more
but it's just as emotional as anything
that's in God of War 18 or Ragnarok look
I'm not saying that they don't have some
emotional moments uh but what I will say
is I just I feel
I feel like they they went so much into
how the game looks and presents
they forgot
the foundation that God of Wars built on
and it irritates me some man it does it
irritates me some
yeah I got you man oh maybe see some
ponies mad
I don't know what they say uh so some
will be uh gotta wise also might have
Warfare too
God of War 3 in the first two hours of
God of War 3 is better than anything in
Ragnarok and 18.
like God of War intense bro when people
say oh fighting uh voter that that was
an epic that was the most epic moment in
God of War that was a good moment
but the the beginning of God of War 3
can't be matched by anything and I'm not
even talking about just God of War tell
me another game
that builds up the way that game was
built up where you just pop in like
literally just think about where they
ended God of War 2.
Kratos climbing Mount Olympus on the
Titans and he's looking up at Zeus and
he's pretty much like yeah you thought I
wouldn't [ __ ] now what like
and and it's how part three stop off
yeah yeah
that that's my point it's just like God
of War three
is the best God of War by far that's
just my opinion like I do think when you
get to God of War two and one
I would start to I would start to say
you can you could fight pretty
confidently if if Ragnarok in 18 is
better than those two games I do think
you can have that that conversation
pretty well done uh I wouldn't get mad
at you well I wouldn't get mad at you I
don't care about your opinion regardless
but I wouldn't get mad at anyone that
would say something like that because I
say okay I can feel that but if you try
to tell me God of War Ragnarok in 2018
is better than God of War 3 you've lost
me because I just I don't see I just
don't see it
um
yeah there I mean
they're the same character but they're
totally two different types of games
and what's funny is it's this
I will say one thing and I just wanted
more context behind
God of War 3 and and the new God of Wars
you know what I'm saying like and people
people literally just said uh because I
put in there they said the reason that
the blood and like you know uh all all
that stuff from God of Wars the old ones
wasn't in this one is because Kratos is
moving on from that life I'm like but he
has no problem ripping ripping like
behemoths apart no problem taking an ax
and putting it on a boulder and and just
literally popping an ogre's face into
like a giant pimple
got no problem doing that but blood
that's where it goes and that's why I
want to ask you dirt do you think that
they're doing that
on PlayStation's behalf or you think
Saint Monica is choosing to downplay
that part of God of War because if you
look last it was part two has a lot of
that
it's got a lot of Gore a lot of violence
that's a good question man
oh wow so you're asking me do I think
them kind of downgrading the blood
um well I wouldn't say downgraded but
not having as much blood as they had in
previous that's a good question but like
you said the last of us too was brutal
they had some brutal kills on there
maybe no I mean I can only think maybe
it is uh it's only Santa Monica maybe
this year I think it's a decision in
Santa Monica I really do because
and I don't know because
Sony is pretty famous for like letting
their games do stuff but other games
they don't they like to censor doing it
so you know maybe it is them but it just
it just doesn't make sense and I get it
this is a different type of God War but
it's like to me that's one of the
foundations of God of War is like you
know it's going to be gory you know it's
going to be brutal like you know that
game is gonna do it and I think that's
the part that just irritates me the most
is like you play in this game
and you cut like a like a dude's arms
off and there's like no blood there like
at all and then but if you know that
same kill animation was in God of War
one two and three it would be spraying
blood right one thing that kind of like
took me out of the emergence just how
the bodies disappear in God of War
Ragnarok I don't I think it definitely
did that in 18 but yeah it just maybe
they do that to try to like
okay even if there was blood that would
just disappear
I don't know the the reasoning behind
that
but yeah I mean what it is yeah I mean
that part doesn't bother me too much it
it like reminds me of Blade movies you
know how like he killed the vampires
they like disintegrate
that part doesn't bother me much
so let's let's get to the juicies man no
52 minutes and 25 seconds
let's talk about the Video Game Awards
let's go man all right so I am going to
move this over the screen is going to
change do you need the link to this
I'll put it in the chat just so you can
follow along there it is
all right so
bam
all right so here's the Video Game
Awards
so let's let's let's go over the Video
Game Awards
uh I'm not gonna go over all these I
feel like some of these categories I'm
not really too uh familiar with do you
have it up yet yeah all right tell me
we'll leave game of the year for last go
go bottom to top and tell me which one
you want to go over in the categories
all right um
hold on before screening
uh because I'm looking right now
see the way mines is I got to do mines
oh wait a minute I can't go straight to
31 mine is like different
oh that's unfortunate yeah my eyes are
like I let's let's start with this one
while you do that let's do the most
anticipated game
okay
which it's not Center I don't know why
it's not Center but um
see it on the screen we got Final
Fantasy 16
Hogwarts Legacy
uh Resident Evil 4 Starfield and The
Legend of Zelda tears of Kingdom you
know what I'm gonna do these live with
you guys I'm gonna do these live with
you guys you guys gonna see my uh
my my goals all right so what do you
think's gonna win that
what I think well yeah okay what you
want and what you think
um I think Zelda doesn't want to win I
want Starfield to win because I'm a bot
because
I
haven't
I don't okay first off
part of me thinks Resident Evil 4 is
gonna win
really because like
there's hype behind Zelda
but I don't really think they've showed
enough to really hype people yet you
know what I'm saying
when Resident Evil 4 came out the
internet stopped talking
high for that bro I'm hyped for that
so um I don't know I guess I'm just
thinking this Zelda is Zelda bro and
people like even though they haven't
shown much of it I think that's going to
help them like people really anticipate
more of it
there's like no hype whatsoever for 15.
Final Fantasy 16 there's like no High
Point did they do a Trader like two
weeks ago and nobody care right it was
like a brand new trailer unless I'm
mistaken it wasn't like a new trailer
like two weeks ago and nobody cared I
haven't seen really no one talk about
that game and it's sad I used to be a
huge Final Fantasy fan I like the older
final fantasies and I really mess with
seven but like these newer ones I'm
gonna play 16 obviously because most
likely I'm gonna review it but it is
what it is uh I'm a vote for that's what
I'm gonna vote for okay so you're going
for resident before I'm actually high
for that game though um I'm I'm gonna
say Zelda but you have one before cool
that's that's what's up
I'm actually going to vote all right so
here here's the first thing that people
are gonna like how you get to that
because you got to go up at the top and
click um uh view categories
oh oh okay now okay all right so create
content creator of the Year this is the
first one that really upset people
um you got Carl Jacobs which I have
every he's winning that like he he's
like the biggest one of the biggest if
not the biggest twitch streamer on right
now
lugwig rebellion and I uh naboro and uh
QTC QT Cinderella I don't know we're
moving on with that though yeah why is a
belly in there
uh isn't he just a Twitter guy
so no disrespect to Rebellion when is
tweeting become a Content creation
yeah when is tweeting have become
content creation because I feel like
I feel like this this is wrong right
there is a thousand other people that
deserve that middle spot over him right
that actually makes content
we deserve that spot more than he does
right because we actually make contact
news yeah all he does is tweet news
and it's just like I I personally feel
like he was given that because he said
he was leaving Twitter if that man
didn't leave Twitter you think he'd be
on this list probably not yeah I think
I think that's exactly what happened I'm
gonna say Carl Jones wins this because
he he's gotten so much bigger here
recently I wouldn't be surprised I don't
want lukewig to win because I feel like
he's won before
um I know none of these people best
multiplayer
oh this is going to be interesting
um
all right so Call of Duty Modern Warfare
2 Multiverse OverWatch 2 Splatoon 3 and
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Revenge why
is Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles on this
it's not a multiplayer game it's
definitely not as it's a co-op game I
think they've gotten some mixed like
multiplayer games or in co-op games are
two different things
right it's so frustrating that we know
stuff but for some reason the dude
running this whole thing is like why is
T why is Teenage Mutant even able to be
nominated for this I will never
understand that then you got Splatoon 3
OverWatch who you think's winning this
OverWatch 2. oh
I'm I'm I'm leading for these three
middle ones
I just don't know which one part of me
feels like they might try to give
Splatoon
like a a bone but OverWatch has gotten
really big
it is
Splatoon 3A man I know I know I'm gonna
go OverWatch though but I won't be
surprised with Splatoon 3 wins to be
honest with you though we got best uh
best sports and racing game uh f122 FIFA
23
uh NBA 2K 23 Gran Turismo 7 and whatever
the hell that last one is ulio world
if granny Christmas seven wins this I I
riot
bro why zt7 nominated
well they didn't nominate
Forza Horizon 5 last year
um Forza Horizon 5 deserve that this
does yeah yeah this is the stuff that'd
be getting me that's like
like Jeff
you mean it'll tell me when we get to
game with you you guys are gonna really
hear it
I don't believe one minute that he
doesn't have any form of influence
whatsoever on these choices all right
because it feels like every the fact
that death stranding was even nominated
in that stacked year shows everything
you need to know right
I don't know I I really don't know who
to pick for this how how big was 2K this
year
2K is always a solid game but the
microtransactions is really starting to
piss people off because most of the
reviewers said say you know like the
game itself is great but the
microtransactions are so bad on 2K bro
it's it's so bad so I don't see them
winning I don't know who's going to win
this one honestly I'm gonna say the last
one because it's only one I can like I
don't care about nothing but I have not
I have no idea some reason they always
be giving like these little Indies like
the those those things like they'll be
giving them that uh
oh okay thank you Donna Taco I haven't
realized that Forza won best sports game
last show thank you I ain't realized
that all right so you none of you guys
care about best Simmons strategy uh best
family game
this is interesting it's a bunch of
Nintendo games
Splatoon 3 is going to win this one I
don't know man
Splatoon 3 buddy
saying
[Music]
um
I know everyone's saying like a Lego
Lego
winning this you don't be crazy if Lego
if Lego wins this and uh
it does in like all these Nintendo games
don't win this
you know what's worse getting getting
nominated four times for a category or
having the one game that's nominated
that's not yours go in
oh man
oh I don't know
Maybe
I think what's worse probably getting
nominated four times
yeah I think that would be worse than
not being nominated at all is being
nominated taking up the entire category
is still losing
[Music]
fighting game people got pissed about
this
um I'm not a fighter game a fighting
person and I know uh saifu Seafood
whatever it's got a seafood yeah sifu is
not a fighting game I don't fight
I don't have fighting friends for the
most part you know I I that's a lie but
bro sifu is a action Game Boy you fight
these other games are one-on-one
fighting games you know
it shouldn't be in this category
I don't know why it's in this category
because you punch people I guess you
know what it kind of it kind of makes me
feel like
saifu isn't going to win any other
categories it's in so they threw it in
here to give it a chance because it's
kind of weak year on on fighting games I
don't play it but I know
out of this one I'll probably say
multiversals
yeah I think Multiverse is going to win
that too Multiverse is a big movement
when it first came yeah yeah I kind of
played it just kind of slowed down a
little bit okay best role-playing game
right here flame I want to say triangle
strategy flame but I know if I say
triangle strategy I'm gonna lose
everything in me wants to say Eldon ring
but then everything in me is like
I'ma lose I want to see that Z I want to
say Xeno Chronicles three that's what I
think's gonna win it that's what I think
so I think the same unless Elder range
is dominated if this live a live game
wins it I'm gonna be I'm gonna be upset
this game does not deserve this I beat
this game and reviewed this game yeah
triangle shred now I've beat all these
games almost yeah all of them but uh but
Pokemon I beat all of them but Pokemon
all right
best action adventure again that one's
always fun why is stray on action
adventure get out of here man why even
uh Tony is more action astray
oh my God what is with this cat game
did you play stray
I played for about an hour it was okay I
actually want to go back and finish
playing it but it was is there any
combat in this game at all
I played about an hour though I I played
no did you call anyone bite anyone the
whole hour you played I don't I don't
recall that but like I said I only
played it for an hour
I think Horizons went in this one
uh I think Horizon is going to win zilch
zero this one right here
um will probably be
God of War
got a war that's that's uh because I'm
expecting Elder Arena to win game of the
year best action game
I think this is the one where sifu could
actually win this uh but part of me
thinks they might give a million out of
three they might get with the Bayonetta
bro because I don't think Bayonetta got
nominated for anything else but this
game yeah they might give to being there
they might you know it was neon white
game is it any good A lot of people like
the neon white game uh it might get it
too this is a this is a hard Video Game
Awards but it's a ridiculous Video Game
Awards at the same time
pretty good yeah yeah if any other wins
it wouldn't surprise me
uh we're not doing best VR best
community support
Apex Legends Destiny 2 Final Fantasy 14
fortnite no man's sky
what's going on here man what you
thinking oh and keep in mind it's all
sponsored by Discord
I'm going to say
fortnight
Fortnight yeah bro they keep they they
keep all the new characters on fortnite
they they keep updating fortnite bro I'm
gonna say Destiny too Destiny though
thanks yeah I'm gonna say Destiny too
um
best mobile game we ain't touching that
best ending
I want coat of the Lambs deserves this
yeah so I'm gonna say Cult of the Lambs
I'm gonna let my emotions take over I'm
gonna let my emotions take over
technically you would think it would be
straight since it's actually voted for
it we don't talk about straight that
game don't exist
I'm going to say well you say quote of
the Lamb I will probably agree but I'm
going to go I I want to say Tony
yeah I'm saying I didn't play it but I
played the demo yeah yeah Tony was
pretty good yeah actually became pretty
challenging later in the game I didn't
finish it but uh it was best ongoing
game engine impact
Fortnight Final Fantasy 14.
Destiny 2
and Apex Legends I think that's almost
identical to the last to the to the best
community is that literally the same
ones hold up best community pretty much
I think no no man's Sky yeah
um
uh I want to say against an impact uh
but part of me feels like they they
might give this to Apex Legends you
think so
yeah
yeah
I could see that because fortnite really
won these in a long time yeah
yeah I agree aqueous Legends I enjoyed
Apex
uh okay he he these these last ones is
the [ __ ] okay
games for impact
and I actually liked it
sleeper I remember people were talking
about that game I hope that's Falls wins
a one because I think it was good yeah I
actually liked it
look at this oh nothing but PlayStation
people for the most part god of war God
of War Horizon is literally half the
panel yeah
uh
I'm gonna say Christopher Judge man that
dude was awesome
even though the the M mortality game I
played that I finished it I still cannot
tell you how I finished that game but I
just got the achievement problem oh
I think they're going to give it to a
Plato
they should because I thought she did
that was a great game by the way did you
finish yet oh you said like I don't like
this you like it 30 frames the same for
me oh that's right the game was fired up
man it was a good game it was a really
good game best audio Design This is a
good one
I don't know why four is a uh why uh
Gran Turismo is part of this
um
oh
actually Gran Turismo probably be the
best bet for these
because I know God is totally I know Cod
is not going to win but the sound design
is pretty damn good I'm giving it to
Gran Turismo because I feel like car
sounds and stuff is probably the most
visible out of all those yeah best art
Direction let's go to the best art
Direction
it is Elder ring God of War Ragnarok I'm
so sick of tired of seeing those first
three everywhere and why are you
straight a stray on here
yeah
oh man hey I'll tell you scoring I'm not
really into the game yet I'm going to
give it another try but it's
brother I think sport actually has a
chance of winning this one hey the art
direction is pretty damn good at scoring
bro I actually personally feel like
score could win this win this category
so I'm saying yeah
I'm with you
scoring
best narrative
I don't think Elder Wings literally
almost the exact same games that we just
saw
I want the other ways to be updated I
can't even have a hell of a narrative
um immortality narrative was I'm telling
you that game was I think it's gonna
come between the PlayStation games two
dollar super trap from flame literally
the Sony Awards give me death it kind of
really is yeah I think it's between the
PlayStation games I mean I don't know a
plagues tell people really like that
maybe you'll snap I enjoyed that yeah
brother I think they're gonna give it to
God of War
you think so yes someone said best
narrative is Twitter
foreign
best game Direction
um
Elden ring
God of War Ragnarok
Horizon forbidden West those three and
straight again again
no how was playing as a cat the best
game Direction explain to me this house
someone put in the comments section uh
in the chat chat what is stray's
Metacritic score
96 or something the way they I don't
know man when we're gonna get an iron
Lords award show make it happen attic
this is ridiculous
um
I would like to do an 83 someone said I
would like to do uh an award show but
hey you know it's funny I usually do one
uh live for the past two years we did in
the war so it was actually pretty funny
I say like you know stuff like Pony of
the year and oh yeah like most most
exhausting topic oh that's cool I like
that that's unique yeah
um
best gain Direction I feel like Elder
and ring might win this I'm telling you
as far as game Direction immortality
might have a shot I've never played a
game like that even though it's a like
what you call a real like a movie game
with real people real actors
I've never played a game quite like that
and I'm gonna go I think that game has a
shot
I'm gonna have to play where can I play
that game man it's a game fast okay I
might have to play that before I choose
these games it's really weird bro it's
really weird it's um
but I like to I don't know how I
finished it I just kept on playing it
it's just I don't know like you got to
figure out what happened to this like
this woman and um you know she's an
actor she did three different movies and
they're showing you scenes from the
movies behind the scenes and it's really
interesting stuff man once you figure
out how to do it but it's yeah
game of the year
oh
a plagues tell record him Elden ring God
of War Ragnarok Horizon forbidden West
stray Xenoblade Chronicles 3.
I can understand
why Horizons on here I don't agree with
it I think there's better games that
came out this year than Horizon but I
can understand why it would be on here
but stray
it makes zero sense to me how playing a
game is a cat is considered the best
game that's came out this year how do
you realistically and with the straight
face telling me playing the game is a
cat is more effective than playing game
playing something like plagues tell
playing Elden ring playing God of War
playing Horizon forbidden West playing
Xenoblade Chronicles 3.
Cult of the Lambs deserve that spot over
stray right if they had to do any they
should have probably put cold on the
land one tunic deserved that spot over
straight yeah anything that came out
this year deserved that spot over
straight
is pretty much a cat simulator until you
prove me otherwise
I don't understand
how that happened I just don't get it
and for some reason everything in me
let's say watch straight win this [ __ ]
how mad you guys think if straight Wins
Game of the Year Twitter gonna be
man let me tell you something straight
away
if straight Wins Game of the Year
I think people might ban the game awards
or or just say you know you're fixed
here there's no stray has zero chance of
winning
zero chance of winning game of the year
part of me thinks there's a chance
there's like a 30 chance it wins 30
percent
I don't you know how it is once like
that unique experience comes up and
people said it was so Lively playing as
as a cat we gotta do it this is so
amazing it's a cat you were a cat
but you get what I'm saying like yeah
games that do something different
usually get a lot of attention
but I just I just don't understand why
Strays on this list you know
I feel like we'll get to that in a
second
I just don't like I don't like this list
I just don't
um you literally have seen a plague tale
Elden ring God of War Horizon almost on
every nomination every one of them right
and it's not just one or two
they come in groups of three to four
almost every nomination of one of these
four games if not all four of them
and you know look at this list in three
of these games are exclusive to
PlayStation
um
God of War
stray and Horizon forbidden West you
know part of me feels like if if stray
wasn't a PlayStation exclusive it
wouldn't be up here nearly as much yeah
if it was a multi-plat it would
I really
it's hard to really come out here and
say Jeff isn't influencing these even
remotely when you see stuff like him
going after writing a Bible to tell you
why you should buy God of War
like and I get that's just his opinion
and that's fine
but to me I'm looking at something like
this and I'm like
this isn't a good look
and the fact that you got
oh
I'm sorry I would say the fact that you
got stuff like saifu
uh sifu is is in a fighter section you
got like uh you got the content creator
thing going on like
I just don't get it what was he gonna
say no this is
this guy in the chat dark times he must
be a PlayStation Fanboy because they
just want to talk about sales he said
the place tell didn't even sell a
million straight so better than the
place tell like
I don't know man if you look at the
Oscars they don't go by what movie made
the most money they go by the best movie
I'm just saying man it's always it's
always about sales with these guys man
and and it and then straight I'll sell
the place now did it I don't know I
don't know it's just frustrating like
how would you want them to do
the Video Game Awards how you how would
you do it
it's it's that's a tough question
because it's like an easy question to
answer it really is yeah people will sit
there and say all this kind of stuff
Jeff dude this Jeff does that look I'm
not saying Jeff isn't dropping the ball
with the Video Game Awards but I'm
saying the people that say they have
Solutions in the comment section it's
not that simple it's it's not because
think about everything is based on
opinion and people say oh well go buy
the highest Metacritic scores well those
are opinions
those are opinions are from people's
reviews it's that's a hard question to
answer
um you know maybe you if you did like
dark times said go by sales no if that's
the case mad Madden will be game of the
year you know so you don't want to do
that either so that is a difficult
question how would you do this so I
don't know man
popularity you know we just don't know
here's the thing you can't let popular
choice win game of the year or be the
most popular game yeah
um maybe let the popular choice choose
the games that go in it but then again
you're just gonna have a bunch of
popular games go in there but to me
that's already happening the majority of
these games are popular games yeah so
it's just like what's the harm in trying
like next year
just let people
pick denominations
and then let the and I think because I
think they had like seven percent or
like ten percent choose game of the year
and the rest go to the industry
the players got to go high higher than
that maybe 20 or 50 50. because I feel
like when you're giving it
to the vgas
a lot of this turns out to be
what's what I'm looking for
politics a lot of this turns out to be
gaming politics I don't agree with it I
don't um I think that
it's here's the thing
regardless where the Video Game Awards
is
be grateful we have a video game awards
we get grateful that we have something
like that
a lot of Industries don't have nothing
remotely close to that the the video
game industry is big enough that people
feel like money is to be made by doing
one so that's good
um is Jeff Keeley the one that should be
doing it I don't know because I feel
like
making money is definitely important and
I'm not going to undermine that he needs
to make that back to ensure that he can
do one next year we got a five dollar
Super Chat from Robert not uh this first
step is to make fans of the year for the
whole year not just 80 of it I agree I
agree so
the first thing you can do is
I see this this topic is really
interesting because there's not a lot of
information on there we've never had
like multiple of these of these vgas
like for the most part we had the one
that Jeff's doing who had the one before
Jeff that's all
um we don't have like a huge thing
um I just don't like the fact that when
he does the vgas he focuses on the money
Morty focuses on celebrating the games
like you're rushing devs off doing their
speech to accept the reward yeah look
you can make money and stop not do that
look money has to be a priority but you
can easily have money be 50 and
celebrating the developers and
Publishers collecting these Awards be
the other 50 we don't have to push one
down to get the other up right and I
feel like
Hugh has no problem spending like
two minutes talking about a McDonald's
sponsorship but he won't
he won't let a developer like some some
developers don't even get to go on stage
and get their award
like they they collected off screen
right
so what do you got to say about this
Dart what's going on in your mind
um let me get a Super Chat first for
Donna Taco oh God the actual game of the
year list should be number one Splatoon
three number two billionaire three
number three Chad Kirby number four
Mario and rap plus Rapids two number
five Xenoblade Chronicles three number
six Elder ring I guess so he couldn't
find a sixth uh because Pokemon can't be
used because it's going to be after I'm
sure there's a sixth Nintendo game you
can use I hope you didn't run out of
Nintendo games you got a five dollar
super Randy G vga's only good for
announcements the show itself is
terrible I agree with you and Microsoft
puts that show and Microsoft puts that
show on his back cause Hey listen don't
forget 2019 they shocked the world with
that hellblade 2 and 6 uh Xbox series X
oh trying to be showing the system yeah
he could have put triangle strategy on
that oh okay so do you have anything to
say about Donna talk who's uh absurd
list because I know you love that
Splatoon
his list is very biased it's it's biased
her here donataku oh Pokemon uh he
Pokemon that Pokemon game that came out
that last year yeah but I watch it like
we stream it you know right before a
couple of of the categories but just for
the new games shown if you think about
it uh I believe was it last year or
maybe it was 2020 they show Callisto
protocol
because I was like what is that game
that game looks interesting of course
you know 2019 Xbox reveal Perfect Dark
is in development they've had some big
games we announced at the show not just
Xbox exclusives but this game's period
so that's it that is something I like
about the show I don't really care less
about the wars you know just talk points
but
new stuff if we had to do a whack
nomination announcement nominations
let the developers actually collect
their rewards man like you know
the Esports I don't think you really
need like
I don't understand why Esports gets such
a highlight
but other thing like
best lead developer doesn't you know
what I'm saying like why is Esports good
I guess it's probably money you know a
lot of money and you know oh yeah
Esports
is a relatively big thing and I'm not
saying it's not uh Esports is huge but
people think people don't realize how
big Esports really is it's gigantic but
it's just like to me
it's just like bam
give us good announcements
give us
tell us what what food we need to buy
that day because I know they're gonna
have some of that
and
I just get annoyed that I feel like
something like that's big but it's
eventually going to crumble because it's
not being
the actual Focus around games isn't
being upheld like sooner let's say
Microsoft decides
we're done announcing big games because
we're going to start building our own
shows and they and they pull out of the
Video Game Awards
what do they really have at that point
then
they're in trouble then if like if
Microsoft does that if Sony does that
yeah they're definitely trouble because
the the Sony doesn't really show up it's
not really show up at all they don't
yeah that's true because the awards
isn't enough yeah you're right that's
not enough that's the award we really
don't care what's you know like like
game of the year is really just bragging
points right just bragging rights yo you
bots we got three games nominated oh
yeah yeah that's all it is what happens
if Xenoblade Wins Game of the Year
all of those games on that board and
Xenoblade beat Elden ring
they say it's a Forza Horizon bro God of
War yo I kind of want that to happen
that's worse than straight because the
straight one people would get upset but
they would say yo the PlayStation fan
boys would say it was still one of our
games
but if if Xenoblade won and uh Donald
talk was people got the W because Xbox
people don't have a w up there we we
hurting man we hurt we don't get there's
no W in this for us so we just gotta
strategically put parts on the board
that benefit us
hey that's it bro listen brother they
had a pretty good 2021 they got
nominated for the most games last year
but this year hey man let's sit back and
enjoy the show right yo let's see if I
can join the show that's all we can do
uh oh did we ever say what you think the
game of the year is going to be I think
we both said yeah
I got a question for you I saw uh Cole
Eastwood put post this on Twitter he
said that I guess someone from digital
Foundry said that one of the best people
in the industry right now
is Coalition yeah I was literally just
looking at that tweet from Colt where
you just said that yeah do you think
coalitions on a naughty dog level like
on the rail
um
graphically
uh well yes
I'm just not sure uh story wise if
they're there yet talk about the package
as a package
um
yeah well not not the entire package yet
I agree with that they're they're not
there yet because I would like to see
them outside of Gears you know I'm
saying to see like what they're really
made of because gears gears five and
gears five Hive Busters I still feel is
underrated as far as graphically and
that game was like yes fire was running
60 FPS I want the Xbox One X and people
don't talk about that a lot
um but yeah they're right underneath
them but I do want to see them in
something outside of Gears I I want to
see gear six don't get me wrong but I
would love to see them do an original Ip
in their own Vision you know what I'm
saying Randy G said thinks Sonya went
out something good at VGA I don't know
buddy
um I have been told Microsoft will be
there in big big shape
um I have been told one of them but I'm
not allowed to share it
uh so you guys are just the way to the
eighth the next month but here's the
thing
I want
Microsoft to do well and I think that
their Studios a lot of their studios are
very prominent and they have a lot of
potential
but I will be the first person to come
out and say
Microsoft has no one on the level as
Saint Monica or naughty dog I do think
they have people on the level of of
Insomniac I'm sorry I do think they have
people on the level of that but as far
as the rest like they have nothing that
compares to those two Studios like not
even a little bit
um I think coalition
in the future
and that's a theory in the future maybe
we gotta see what their game not yet
okay we got to see how hellblade 2 pops
out because I do think I think hellblade
could be nurtured to become a naughty
dog like the the quality of that but
I think Microsoft's got Studios that
could compete with the quality in
different ways like obsidian where you
know it gives you a different type of
game but I don't think they have anyone
on that quality
um you know Insomniac I think
I think a lot of Microsoft Studios is
hitting where Insomniac hits I'm sorry
it makes good games but I don't think
they made anything revolutionary
um Spider-Man 2
great game but I wouldn't put it on the
quality of something like last of us too
or God of War
uh you know when you play those games
they hit different Spider-Man 2 did good
but I don't think it hit that different
um Ratchet and Clank
good game
but it's nowhere near on the the level
of those games
I would say gears five is more closer
to like a a God of War a naughty dog
type of game in a state Monica game but
I do feel like
gears five isn't on that level either
uh but it's close it's just not on that
level it's like it's like it's like a
notch just a little Notch obsidian I
feel like is on obsidian is on uh
insomniac's level and let me say this
attic um I don't disagree with you
at this point I do agree
um but I guess
with Xbox to me is still the question
mark because
we haven't seen some of these Studios
these new Studios they bought 100 under
Xbox with Xbox resources that's why I
mentioned Ninja Theory I can't wait to
see Ninja theories like hellblade 2 what
that game is going to be
I believe it's going to be something
special like we haven't seen games like
a vow you know because like in the past
obsidian always kind of worked
um like they never really had a well I
guess they have big budget games but
they always did work for other people
you know they did
um you know like Fallout New Vegas for
uh uh uh uh Bethesda they did South Park
stick of true for what was that I don't
know uh you'll be solved for whoever
made that damn game so they always did
stuff for other people but I can't wait
to see them with a big budget what
they're going to be able to do and it's
you know for some of the other Studios
they have so and I also want to see
double fine what they're going to be
able to do now I'm not talking about
graphically
but Psychonauts 2 was an incredible game
but like double fine with a big budget
with freedom
I would love to see what they're going
to make I can't wait to see that next
thing I think double fine you're going
to see AAA product games but they're
taking they're technically going to be
in a double a level
okay I think it's gonna be like a
hellblade a hellblade scenario where
hellblade is technically a double A but
you could see that quality and you think
it's AAA yeah uh I do think hellblade
has the potential to be
a very successful game for them
um
as far as who competes with with Saint
Monica Sony St Monica and naughty dog
rock star only people I can think of
like in the entire industry yeah I agree
with that um they when they make games
it moves the world those three Studios
compete with each other I don't think
one of them is above the other those
three Studios have proven uh where over
and over again
that we can make quality games sure you
can disagree with certain aspects such
as like Last of Us Part two story but
when Naughty Dog announces their next
game it does not matter people are gonna
listen yeah uh I do think Microsoft
obsidian uh you know that that's a very
prominent studio uh they don't make the
tight same type of games that naughty
dog in them make but I do think that
they they hit above their weight
I'm curious what a vow does
they got Bethesda software Studios
people might look up look down on them
because of the the state fall of 76 came
in which wasn't technically that studio
it was another Studio
but they can hit above their weight you
know I would say that once upon a time
it's a sleeper yeah what playground
playground we'll have to see how Fable
shows up that's what I'm saying because
people only play where I'm gonna change
the game bro look I know it's it's
messed up with me to say but I can never
put
a car simulator or a car arcade game
against something like a god of war or a
lot oh yeah oh yes yeah yeah I agree
with that you can't really compare that
but I mean when it comes to Quality yeah
and I believe uh playground games
um I don't know when he said this but uh
like what's the name of the guy that
runs playground games it's Joseph
something uh I don't um yeah but he said
they want to be the best studio out
there
and I believe they're they're gonna I
believe Fable is going to be absolutely
incredible
playground games I know they only made
Forza excuse me
Horizon games but I just really feel
they're going to really put out some
quality stuff man and um that's just how
I feel about it and don't forget about
uh Crystal Dynamics and I'm just talking
stuff I think
I think there are Studios that could
evolve and become
there I think Coalition is a rock skip
away from becoming on that level they
just gotta they gotta straighten out
some of their story narrative I feel
like sometimes they drop the ball there
um but besides that people could sit
there they could say what they want
about the multiplayer no one cannot deny
me the first two to three acts of God no
the first two acts and the fourth Act of
Gears of War 5 is is amazing and you you
could Theory you could say that if they
would have fixed that act three before
it came out that it would uh like the
desert yeah if they would have fixed
that third act they made it more like
the icy the snow mountains and
you could say that that's on a God of
War level yeah but the problem is God of
War hits the whole game most the time it
rarely drops below peak level and seems
like Coalition does drop the ball in
some areas or less someone said they
need uh Cliff Pulaski back no
um I think Microsoft should reach out to
him and let him run his own Studio
yeah because I think there's still a lot
of ideals that they could use on there
but unfortunately we don't see them yeah
hey but she has no he got a good point
the Coalition did guess five in three
years which is which is true and I agree
with you addict part like like act one
was amazing two was amazing and act four
was amazing in Gears but the act three
that red sand I don't know what happened
to the like the graphics are like look
cartoony all of a sudden act three was
pretty bad in Gears uh five but
everything else was fire I just stayed
the Coalition oh man they're they're
taking the time because if you think
about last generation they were making
gears games every three years
they're taking their time
and we always say the most important
thing to developers is budget and time
they're getting both of those things so
I can't wait to see what they're working
on
I think it just comes down to
Coalition needs to get certain things
settled and I'm not even saying 343
can't be on that level eventually but I
feel like they need to drop Ayla part of
me feels like that's not their child
that's not their creation and I feel
like maybe because here's the thing just
because they keep dropping the ball in
Halo I still
very comfortably say 343 is a very
talented Studio
it's just when you make a project like
Halo
and you have so many moving Parts you
have the pandemic being thrown in it
it's hard to hit that out of the park
but I feel like if they were given maybe
some new management and they were able
to go to a different direction and make
their own thing I think that they could
actually succeed in that yeah
and I feel like at this point
that's probably what's going to happen
you know obsidian I don't think we have
nothing to worry about upsetting I think
a valve is going to come out there and
be a hit I think anything pretty much
obsidian makes you know pandemic might
not be my type of game
but clearly people loved it that did
play it I I will say it you know it
could have got a little bit more reviews
uh it's kind of interesting the amount
of people that actually reviewed that
game it's an obsidian game one would
think people would review it but it's
it's just crazy that it got the amount
of reviews it did get Iron Mike with the
five dollar super Ragnarok had several
portions that drive way worse than
anything in Gears five
I agree with you but I feel like
Those portions particularly in like the
middle of Ragnarok
they still had lore going on they stored
a lot of energy going on now there was
one part we were picking fruit and I
know for the people that know they know
that was the worst part God of War
Ragnarok and I think that is what I felt
in in the third uh Act of of Gears five
but the problem is is
I feel like that acting gear is act
three in Gears five was way longer than
that portion of you collected fruit
yeah you know you were doing that I
haven't got to that part yet yeah
there's a part where you're collecting
fruit that's all I'm saying I want to
ruin it for anyone uh people that know
what I'm talking about you know what I'm
talking about I just felt like gears
five needed more in that third area of
like the the like the lightning storm
they needed more stuff like that to make
that area more unique what they try to
do is they try to have another snow area
in the the desert area but they didn't
make the desert area unique in any way
right right yeah I agree
I agree because the snow area was fine
yeah so I mean it is what it is
um I do think we'll see what do you
think we're gonna see at the Video Game
Awards
that's a good question you mean from
like me from Xbox right
yeah
you know we talked about this on wbg um
I felt
maybe it's time for okay like they're
gonna show someone unannounced game
that's the question I don't know it
would be the coalition's unannounced
game compulsion
um I don't know I don't know and I just
can't I'm just kind of guessing
compulsion
I'm going to reveal their game
that could obviously be wrong but that's
what I'm rolling with compulses
unannounced game
do you think we'll see another hellblade
no no I think they're gonna
wait to show the E3
uh like a real gameplay slice I think
yeah yeah that's that's that that's a
good one that's a good one I think we'll
see about you know it might not happen
we definitely might get a scenario where
that doesn't happen but I have been told
by a couple people that Microsoft is
showing up for the Video Game Awards I I
don't know what context I'm sure they'll
show I hope they don't show nothing new
I don't want to see a new IP we got to
see these games come out like I I I
don't want to see another game they're
gonna wind over my head for another
couple years like show me games that
you've already announced because if you
show games it's not out and you show new
IPS people will say first thing they're
going to say to they're going to take
set the win right out of that cell and
say but what about Fable what about a
vow what about hellblade what about
whatever perfect Dart what about
compulsions game
what about whatever Dune people make an
I.T ID well there's so many things that
they haven't addressed that they need to
address before they make a new IP show
me the games that you already have going
and then I'll get hyped for new IPS
hey you know what I kind of see what
you're saying because we do you know
they they have announced a lot of games
um
I would like to see a little bit more
updates on a couple of those games you
know like we see red fraud uh uh star
Field Force of Motorsport those are
three announced games that's coming next
year
I would like to see will they drop
something in the second half of next
year I would like to see that and I
would like to see you know like what's
the release year for fable is it 2024
what's the release year for Perfect Dark
2024. that's that's something Hellboy
also 2024 2023 a vow so yeah you're
right about that they have a lot of
announced games I would like to hear
some updates on some of those games
and it's just one of those things where
I don't mind if they announce a new game
on on certain conditions like that game
got to come out in six months
six months
I just don't want I don't I'm tired of
people announcing games and it doesn't
come out for years yeah I'm frustrated
with that and that's the point where I'm
just like don't show me new games until
you show me these games that you
announced years ago come out because if
you show me new games I'm gonna say is
there something wrong with the old games
because why do you keep it's like you
you have the fruit in front of my face
but you show me fruit behind me and I
gotta eat this one first
and I don't want to eat this one and
then they show me another fruit way back
here I want to eat this fruit here stop
showing me these three show me this one
like how long ago was it the Fable was
announced five years ago it feels like
oh it's 20 20. it was officially
announced 2020.
yeah so I mean three years ago I guess
that one's a little bit more acceptable
uh but hellblade
that was definitely 2019 yeah we had
2019 a vowed
2019 20. no that was 20 20 also so we're
going four years on one four years on
the other five years on one
yeah it's time yeah some games literally
make are developed in that time like the
whole game
and we keep saying oh you know Fable
isn't coming out to 2025. what
that's a long time bro
it is what it is but we're gonna go
ahead and uh wrap it oh Indiana Jones
that's another one
yeah
I think you know what
um when did Doom Eternal come out 2020
right it was a 2021.
um what did doommy Turner come out y'all
someone chat put in that put in that you
guys know what to do tell me when do
maternal came out
it should be close for them to announce
their next game right
It Like It software
they have a lot of Studios man and um
you're about right though they it's
about time to just get updates so these
games should be
I'm gonna say perfect dog Fable a vowed
hellblade tool those are four games
that should
be either 2023 or 2024. you look at
something like pendant was announced
this year and it's coming out this year
you know what I'm saying thanks y'all it
was the 2020. it's about time for Doom
like a new Doom work then this game will
be announced but go ahead that's just my
only issue it's like I want to just see
the games that's coming out that's all
and
another thing the E3 they better do that
12 month thing again they better do it
because if they don't I'm gonna call
them out for doing it this year
because at that point
you were doing some sleight of hand [ __ ]
and I don't like that
all right but we're gonna go and uh wrap
this up let me do the in the outro yeah
maybe with them time stamps right buddy
we are one hour and 43 minutes
40.
oh okay hold up I'm completely dropping
the ball here
one hour timestamp Mafia leave him alone
he's working on it okay
yeah I'm not scared of these people a
little bit
[Laughter]
too
I actually tried to play pentament last
night I said now I'm I was sleepy so I
said no I wait I'm refreshed to play so
where can people find you at man where
could people find you at oh man I gotta
I gotta spam the um my channel yo uh
check out my channel guys
if you don't know my content I uh I talk
a lot of trash about PlayStation fan
boys I prefer Xbox I'm Xbox dude and we
have a lot of fun on my channel you know
I have a podcast on Monday nights called
WBZ Xbox podcast wbg stands for Weebly
green
you know stop by and check it out
putting my my link in the chat
there you guys go go in there and follow
that man uh put your Twitter in there
too before you uh before you end yeah
follow me on Twitter yeah you guys can
follow me on Twitter at Lord addict IOP
you can follow me on YouTube at gaming
addict I just posted a a spoilers God of
War you know I was gonna make a video
for tomorrow but I think uh I think uh I
don't think that's happening probably
Friday Friday we'll see another video
but I appreciate everyone coming through
we had up to 200 not like 15 20 people
you know uh I appreciate you guys uh
allowing me to to have a two week off uh
it just
pretty chaotic here recently
um I've always been very passionate that
when a game comes out
and I'm very interested in it
that I won't
play game like here's the thing if
there's stuff to play I'm gonna play
games and I'm not gonna come on here and
talk about playing games
um you know
I was so into god of war and plus you
gotta think I I review God of War 2 and
anyone that reviews no the longer time
goes by the worse
the reception you're going to get from
that game is so I was trying to get it
out there in a reasonable manner too but
I appreciate everyone coming through
um it's like I said fall go on there
follow dirt on that Twitter put in the
chat put it in there again dirt follow
them on Twitter follow them on YouTube
follow me on uh Twitter Lord addict IOP
follow me on YouTube gaming edits and
Sunday we're gonna do is Crown the Lords
we're gonna go through just like we did
on here but there's gonna be more on the
line Sunday I'm hoping I take it I don't
think I'm winning this year guys I'm
gonna be real with you I don't think I'm
winning this year but anyway it's nice
seeing everyone we're gonna hopefully
we'll be back next week I don't see why
we won but you know it's it's hard to
tell but anyway until next time this is
Lord addict and Dirk greganing world
so